[Music]
the first trailer for Avengers 4 is
almost upon us
hype has never been higher for the film
so I thought I'd use various reports
sources and eyewitness accounts to piece
together the plot of the highly
anticipated trailer to let you know what
could happen there is a lot of potential
for spoilers here so if you want to go
into the trailer with no prior knowledge
I suggest you turn off now for everyone
else thanks for clicking the video and
let's get into my trailer breakdown for
Avengers 4 so the trailer opens on the
planet that we last saw that is resting
on at the end of infinity war this is
confirmed by multiple sources and seems
like the perfect point to begin the
sequel danus begins to iterate that his
destiny isn't fulfilled yet as there now
exists a rebellion that threatens to
undo the work that he did in balance in
the galaxy you get a close-up of the
Infinity Gauntlet which is nearly
destroyed from the snap inning and the
screen then fades to black it's at this
point that we cut to earth where we see
nebula and Tony landing after returning
from Titan they managed to salvage a
ship from the planet and upon their
arrival they are greeted by Captain
America Thor and black widow Tony and
cap greet each other which shows that
the conflict in infinity war has finally
forced them to put aside their
differences and reform the Avengers we
then get the classic Marvel title
overlay and a couple of shots of the
redesigned Hawkeye who has now become
Ronin this is because his entire family
were wiped out in the snap inning and
it's a nice touch to have them as some
of the victims as they played a big part
in age of Ultron we see tannaz returning
to earth with a large spacecraft and
battling on the planet intercut with
this are images of the shield logo which
confirms that it has been reformed and
went public again this is good news as
the group was seemingly disband at the
end of the Winter Soldier and only made
a brief appearance in age of Ultron Tony
then narrates that Nick Fury was right
from the beginning as he struts along a
Helicarrier in a newly designed suit we
then join Ant Man as he manages to break
out the quantum realm and breathes a
sigh of relief as he lands back on earth
it's at this point that he looks around
to see the streets deserted and his
character is clearly in place to give
exposition to those who may not be fully
up
speed with the events of infinity war we
then get a cut of the battle between
Hulk and dannis and it's great to see
the character making a reappearance as
he was heavily absent in the preceding
film then ash narrates that the team are
strong but he can't allow them to
interfere with the universe's newly
found balance we get a close-up of
Doctor Strange who appears to be in a
desert this shot then pulls out to
reveal a he is in fact trapped in the
soul stone many people theorize that all
those killed in the snapping would be
forced there and this confirms it
we then see Captain Marvel battling
Thanos an ant-man Iron Man and Thor
traveling through the quantum realm in
order to go back in time to the Battle
of New York Loki is pictured walking
along in Chains which confirms the
leaked footage that we have seen we then
see Iron Man with Loki's scepter and the
character removes the mind stone from it
in the present the mind stone then
disappears from the gauntlet and is saw
a Back to the Future and fade out at the
end of the trailer Thanos is seen
smiling with the majority of the
Avengers dead around him which is when
we get our title card and the trailer
cuts to black so what are your thoughts
on the leaked trailer information
have you heard differently and what you
think this means for the movie comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please like it and check
out my breakdown of white Thanos
survives storm breaker which will be
linked at the end of this one this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for take the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]